she's a former top model television
personality TV show host and
entrepreneur she began her career as a
model at age 15 and rose to fame as
becoming the first african-american
woman to be on the cover of GQ and the
Sports Illustrated swimsuit magazine by
the early 2000s she was one of the
highest-paid models in the world
she's Tyra Banks and hear her top ten
rules for success even as a model back
in my modeling days I'd say almost every
single day I heard you can't do this
fashion show because you're black you
can't do that magazine spread because
you're black you can't have this
contract modeling contract because
you're black you can't be on the cover
of a magazine because you're black and
of course they get you down but for some
reason there's something inside of me
that goes you say I can't really watch
me so it's very important to find out
why disease is disease different and
everybody that works on my system knows
it so they don't ever
it's like we call it sagging Nazi so I
encourage everyone dad or will she won't
break through the clutter there's so
much noise there's social media act just
craziness and whether you're the
consumer women or the
business-to-business business that can
have there's just so much clutter how do
you see that that's I feel like um my
career and my business has gotten to
where it is because of my gut so that's
just something a combination of you know
my parents and what they've instilled as
well as you know some education that
I've had and life experience but again
that all goes to me it's still gut gut
gut in order to take my business to the
next level for it to scale for it to be
truly I really want to leave a true
legacy I think that expanding the
definition of beauty is bigger than me
and more important than me and in order
to reach more people and to grow my
business I needed the book smarts I
needed though the minds of those
professors I needed the education to get
there I do not think that I could do it
without the education now I'm sitting
with my accountants and we're talking
you know all net present value and we're
talking about you know depreciation and
you know just so much that had I not
gone to school you know I don't think
that I would have focused on it enough
and I would have been just this girl
that's doing creative and maybe getting
robbed blind huh you know or not being
sustainable what I do is I try to UM
make a negative into a positive a lot
like in my career on a daily basis as as
a producer I'm constantly on America's
Next Top Model on the talk so there's
always a oh that person fell out they're
not going to show up oh this this models
doing this or oh our budget is this and
we just got cut like 30 percent but our
budget got cut I'm always trying to
figure out a way to make it work and
there always is a way
you know collection of leaving the brand
Graham Graham first what I say first
what I stand for it is so fun and so
natural for something like that that's
so obvious so that's about for me to see
you know what's what I'm passionate
about also is what is organic the
smartest business decision I ever made
was retiring from modeling and doing it
in a big way so I was a Victoria's
Secret Angel one of the first angels and
I retired and really big Tyra's what
last walk you know tomorrow night Judah
to 8:00 p.m. you know and and I walked
away in a really big way and I did that
so that I wouldn't be tempted to go back
but I realized yeah not sure if that was
the smartest thing to do because I had a
new talk show back in the day Tyra show
it had not been renewed yet America's
Next Top Model was brand new had not
been renewed yet so here I am putting
all of my eggs into this basket not
knowing if I had you know a true future
with this new television production and
producing and hosting so good decision
but I look back I'm like hmm very risky
very risky but sometimes those are the
decisions that pay off that I like I
reward yeah no I mean I had people like
just going your model and what the heck
you're gonna have a talk show it's gonna
be canceled you're just a model nobody
cares so you know I've always had that
over me oh you're a black girl you're
not gonna be successful as a model so I
feel very taken seriously now when I
walk in a meeting and it's like 10 men
in there in suits I don't feel like I
have to prove myself anymore I feel like
I've I've proven myself
I want business that is bigger than me
that means a lot more than me as a
person I look up to Walt Disney so long
with us and when young kids go to
Disneyland
they think that Disney is just a name
illness analysis committee and that's a
lot of hair lesson if young girls you
know 30s now don't open the tire weights
company retire base picture was a person
just as long as they're there understand
about unique beauty if they don't have
to be a cookie cutter to be beautiful
connect this place or this business and
things that thing participated make him
feel better like Isis to this day I have
to talk to myself when I am walking on
the stage of an award show because I
didn't know this but for years I would
walk out on that stage and I would do
this I would hunch and one day I was
talking to my mom and she's like why do
you do that and for some reason it's an
award show or if you're in front of a
big crowd of people like you don't model
like that you don't host your talk show
like that you don't do top model like
that why when you're in a in front of a
big big crowd like thousands of people
or millions watching at an award show
type of thing do you hunch and then I
was struggling and I didn't understand
why and I realized it's because I did
not want to look like yo Here I am and
I'm all that and I don't know why on
award shows it I can't even say it
happened it happens still so I have to
work on that myself to say I've worked
hard I'm successful you know and work my
butt off
stand up straight stand up proud and
that's something that I still struggle
with
I'll say it [ __ ] come to the line oh
good
you guys in front of me I just wanna
sing one more thing
for Babbitt I admire your emotion right
now it shows to me that this was
something that's very important to you
took me I'm extremely disappointed in
you this is a joke to you
you've been through anger management
you've been through your grandmother
getting her lights turned off to buy you
a swimsuit for this competition
and you go over there and you joke and
you laugh this is serious to this girl's
this should be serious to you looks can
be deceiving
I'm hurt I am but I can't change it para
I Ivan if you can you can't change what
the ground about of it I cannot change
I'm sick of in disappointment I'm sick
all of it I'm not thank you you being
just different obviously I know you're
not if you were sick of being
disappointed you would stand up and you
would take control of your destiny do
you know that you had a possibility to
win you know that all of America is
rooting for you do you know that and
then you come in here you treat this
like a joke you come in here and look at
that and say I can't read that you read
ten times better than half of those
girls over there good you did and you
come in here with a defeatist attitude I
don't have a bad maybe I am angry inside
I've been some stuff off angry yeah
I have never in my life fielded a girl
like this when my mother yells that this
is because she loves me I was rooting
for you we were all rooting for you out
there you learn something from this you
go to bed at night you later you take
responsibility for yourself because
nobody's going to take responsibility
for you
you roll in your eyes and you act like
it's cuz you've heard it all before
you've heard of before you don't know
where the hell I come from you have no
idea what I've been through
but I'm not a victim I grow from it and
I'll learn take responsibility for
yourself
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because one of our
hardcore friends Lucy asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Tyra
Banks is top ten rules had the greatest
impact and meaning for you leave it in
the comments I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon